Well, guys, I am so honored. I am joined today by the absolute royalty of golf podcasting. Honestly, royalty of personalities, too, if I'm being fully honest, the co-hosts of We Need a Fourth, Kenny May, Brian Baumgardner, and my boy, Cooper Manning. Boys, welcome. I'm so excited for you guys. I'm so excited for the podcast.
Thank you so much. This is great. We've been having a blast. This is the threesome that we didn't know we needed in America. And then when I tell people that you guys are doing this podcast, everybody's very excited. You all love golf to varying degrees. Explain a little bit about your relationship to golf.
Well, first off, well, I would say that Kenny loves golf. the most for sure. Like I don't think, I think Kenny loves golf more than Cooper and I love golf combined. He just needs to learn how to play it. So, yeah, I mean, that doesn't love me back. Now, I'm a disabled senior and I play back way back with those guys from the tips. So keep that in mind. I'm just, that's not fair.
I'm trying to learn. I'm trying to learn. I got a lot more to learn, but I do love the game. You know, I was going to ask you about your hockey team up there in Canada. and whether you get distraught. I get incredibly competitive. When it's over, I'm done. Like, it's not, it's not like, I don't carry the joy or the pain for longer than like 25 seconds.
Right. And Coop, you don't get, you're not very competitive in that way. Like, golf for you is a lot of fun. You like to have fun. I mean, you like to bet or whatever, but. I've gotten to the point where I do not like playing golf. As much as I love playing golf, I do not like playing golf. I do not like playing golf with people I do not like, and I won't.
Someone can invite me on the greatest trip. We're going here, and I'm like, who's going? And if it's a bunch of bozos, Coupie is out. I'd rather go play an absolute muni with two guys wearing football jerseys and smoking weed and get a story out of it than some stiff at, you know, some fancy schmancy spot. Well, that makes sense. And this podcast, obviously, is, you know, we need a fourth, so it's golf-centric. But you guys kind of delve into, it's safe to say that you guys go on tangents that aren't necessarily golf-related.
I know there's an upcoming. And we also get very deep. As you, you know, interviewed with us, I mean, we talked High-Lye, we talked Canadian football. We talked about your love of hockey and your love. We try to, we want the whole person. We're peeling back. there's nothing left of the fucking onion by the time it's minced and and we break the person down I guess I like the social aspect of it I love that for that time you're out there
there's nothing to do you're not on your phone you don't have a million things coming at you you're just there and you get to kind of shoot the shit and have a good time and that's that's what I like and that's kind of the vibe that you guys have here on that's what we're trying to do I mean we're trying we're looking for a fourth to play golf with but really we're just looking for a fourth to hang out with um And like you will, for me, golf, I, I don't do yoga. I know that's surprising to a lot of people. This is, by the way, this is breaking news, but I was going to be the name of this show.
I don't do yoga. He's more a tight sheet. I don't do yoga. But I use golf as meditation 100%. Like you get four hours and you're thinking about nothing, you know, not work, out family, not whatever distract you. on your phone, but you're just focusing on putting this little stupid ball into this
little stupid hole, and that it totally resets me. But don't you think as a man in the world you live in today, there's rarely a scenario where you're going to spend four hours with three other guys doing something everybody's enjoying and not, you can't
hide from getting a read on someone. If you spend four hours playing something, you're going to find out a lot, like, is this a good fellow? Do I want to hang around him again? what's he you can you find out because you can ask him anything and it's always fun I usually learn a lot sometimes no people don't ask me anything in return I went well I got that guy figured out but he doesn't know shit about me that's fine too I like that well it's also sort of like I forget which comic does it it's we have the joke here where all come home and my wife will ask so how's so-and-so doing you know is he dating anyone like I don't know he fucking he had an 82 he had a good day like you know yeah Kenny, that is so funny you say my buddy, I don't play golf with anybody more than I do with
our pal, Jason Bateman. J.B. Jackie Bates. And his wife, she'll double back on me. We'll play and then we'll have dinner that night. And she goes, what? Jason didn't tell me any of the stuff that you're telling me. I asked him and he didn't, she goes, what do you guys talk about? I go, I don't know. We're just, you know, we're just
shooting the breeze. Yeah. Next shot, ribbon each other, having a laugh about something. But we don't, you know, you don't get too deep. It's not like, you know, we don't tee off and go and start walking and go, hey, man, you know, I just, I'm really depressed. Doesn't make for a great day. Things are not good at home. She's an eight or seven. Exactly.
Mark, our producer, should be noted, is a stick. He's a very good golfer. I play with him many times over the years. and he reminded me of a story one time we were playing years ago in New Jersey which Coop I know you like I could almost stop there in New Jersey in New Jersey I could almost just stop there right this is like 10 15 years ago in New Jersey
Mark and me in Chris Pratt TV and films Chris Pratt who we adore hilarious guy great guy funniest dude in the room and Pratt about the second or third hole I forget what it was his a shot and he's like who threw my back out and he says, I'm, he says, I'm going to go in. We're like, you want to say, no, no, you guys keep going. I'm just going to go in, and let me just go deal in, and I'll see you guys later.
So Mark and I continue to play. We play a full 18. We're coming in, it's kind of like twilight. We're coming into 18, and just behind the 18th green, we see this thing, this being lying on the ground with his knees up. And it's Pratt, and he's been waiting there for hours for us to come in, lying on the grass just beyond 18. By the way, we drove him back to the, because we were his ride to the city. We drove him back here to New York City. He gets out of the car bent over, and he walked there, and he's like, see you, man, that was a great date.
Fully bent over. I love when people get hurt. I don't know why. Pain and a grown man. I saw a guy kill a goose once. I saw a guy off a tea at Dyker out in Brooklyn off the tea. This guy was a terrible golfer, and he hit a goose and he killed it. I had two clients one time I was playing with, and one guy was up ahead in the bunker.
trying to figure out something and someone's just absolutely hit this shin high two iron right in the lower back and the guy went oh you know goes that and those two started getting in a fight and i just said you know i just laughed my face off by the way you just said i love when someone gets hurt that's like doing something you know they're supposed to be doing you know like well that's why you guys both ridicule me for the leg brace i got a ruin you will doesn't know this i got a right ankle from football way back when so i wear this leg device that lets me do stuff with no pain these guys and j b the jasoner those they killed me for it's like okay let's go make fun of wheelchair people next guys i know but you carry it you carry it around like you're carrying an
an urn of your dead uncle like walking around like that ankle yeah so guys listen we're really excited about we need a fourth this is going to be this is going to be a lot of fun uh when it when is it drop. September 15th. September 15th is a drop date. Thank you, Bomber. This is our only. Every Monday. Every Monday.
Dropping two on the 15th. So there'll be two there if you're listening to this on the 16th. Drop it on the 15th. Jop. I mean, let's reword that. I don't think it's going to give us the best. Deuce on the 15th, fantastic. We need a fourth.
Brian Baumgartner, Kenny Mayne, Cooper Manning. Guys, couldn't be more excited. Sike for you guys and can't wait to listen. Thanks so much. much, man. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Smart. Bless Media. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.